so there's a widespread perception that
a lot of social media status updates on
facebook and on twitter a kind of dial
or gossipy order sandwich related and so
my my collaborator Kurt Luther in
discussion with Michael Bernstein and I
were thinking well what if say a
facebook had a dislike button what would
that tell us how can make these things
more interesting often register your
tweeting in to avoid there's very little
feedback from your followers about what
they liked or what they disliked and
also why so if you start to understand
this then we can start to design tools
and clients to to maybe filter out
certain content or to present content in
different ways and also some of the
emerging kind of norms and accepted
practice on these sites how people are
putting themselves across how people
being perceived so that we can help
people both create more valued content
and also consume valued content to
understand these questions of content
value that we had we needed a lot of
ratings of tweets so we designed a
website called who gives a tweet and
people will come along and advertise
anonymous feedback from both followers
and from strangers using about 40,000
ratings that we got we found that for
these of average user they like about
forty percent of their feet there's a
lot of content there that they're sort
of either just neutral about all they
actively dislike and so for the type of
users we had they really preferred
information sharing or questions to
followers or sort of personal opinions
on things what was a disliked was the
sort of me now sort of current activity
current mood all sort of location for
square location check and stuff like
that so for my findings we might be able
to in the future design tools to better
present information may be certain
followers are going to be displayed in
different ways in your feed but it's
just the size of the content we're going
to filter some content out we know that
over time we could learn you like a
certain type of content from a certain
type of people that may change you know
you leave links from one person you like
personal opinions from someone else some
of these sort of location check-ins may
be better visualized in a different way
maybe they should be on a map
that's going to be a better
representation of them other than just
constantly filling up your feed in the
future we really want to broaden this
one I generalize this understand does
this apply to all Twitter users you know
what different types of communities and
use would exist and how do they value
and how do those values change we also
want to think about how end users could
use this information maybe we had a
Twitter client that as people are
reading their tweets that liking and
disliking stuff so how could we as
researchers use that but also how could
use as a you know Twitter user use that
information as well